[Music]
welcome back to
the record where we talk about whatever
we want
we got shannon back shannon
how was your uh pandemic year
i don't know this past time just chilled
out and popped the baby out
i loved it it was a great one i got
pregnant
so i got pregnant and then i got mad
sick during pregnancy and i was working
was that intentional no i got pregnant
in february
it just happened oh right before long
before she popped off wow i got pregnant
like february 17th
and then the pandemic happened march
18th or something like that yeah but i
didn't want to work anymore
so i was like oh i feel so sick i still
got to work and then i was like but i
don't have to work anymore
so it was quite nice wow and i got to
stay home yeah
and grow a human yeah so it was like a
perfect
perfect time really really it was great
it was a i feel terrible saying that but
it's it's done wondering and he got a
new house my skin cleared up
uh-huh yeah yeah wait you you used to
have
uh yeah yeah i don't remember that
yeah what happened i mean getting
pregnant probably anything else but like
staying home i got to eat better i just
felt like
my whole life was honest i wasn't
traveling as much and like a lot of
things i didn't like about my job
went away with the pandemic what you
mean like i hated useless meetings
like so much time and all stupid
meetings
40 minutes on some parking lot trying to
figure out what spot i can park in and
then like i'm late
it's a lot yeah so now you just zoom in
right zoom in yeah yeah but you just
show up
on set if you need to if i if you need
me that's the thing is like now it's
become more like
if it's necessary yeah it's not just
like a given like i used to travel
for spots so that means like i'd spend
three days of my time to spend
four minutes on a tv show and then get
flown out yeah
was it worth it no no no i mean not like
it used to be
there's nothing i think that gets you
like that
pr um like jk news has probably done
more for my career than nine out of ten
of any tv show i've been on no you're
not the first person that said that
yep i hope that jake i mean you know
what sucks jk news hasn't benefited us
the way that it's benefited
really true it's not even jk news it's
probably more ask the feels if anything
yeah yeah yeah because it was more on
brand too yes exactly
have you tried being a guest on the show
joe you should try something i i will
next time i'll
try it and then maybe i can you know be
like shannon here
and we can welcome our new guest
what's up with you joe we'll give it a
shot we'll see what happens yeah yeah
maybe one day maybe one day he's all
excited like oh [ __ ]
no i remember because ask the feels it
felt way more legit
to have you there because it's like all
right now we have a sex
freaking expert here it's like certified
it's not just a bunch of people talking
about it anymore you know
yeah that was the beginning i guess of
the complaining culture
oh yeah yeah right because that it ended
because of
adpocalypse yeah because all of a sudden
people were like oh youtube should not
be like this
and then they started creating all these
like pay walls and like who can and can
what can and can't be viewed and it got
weird
and then it's just continued ever since
i was a canton camp big time
can't be viewed can't be provided for
but you do a lot of uh media like like
tv
and all that stuff too um but is that
is it all to kind of like cultivate the
fans to come
to your brand like on your instagram or
oh hell yeah yeah she's an author i mean
it's a whole thing the whole point is
like it's like exposure i guess
right so that it builds the brand and
when you go to sell something you can
sell it for more a book or whatever it
is that you do or
of course but um like yeah you build up
the name so
back in the day like i remember like
getting on good morning america was like
my thing like yeah
get up there i gotta get on there and
then it happened this year
[ __ ] maybe my grandma hollered at me
like even the people you thought would
watch that show
like nobody saw it so gma
with steffy stephanopoulos pretty
relevant now huh who is that who's on it
isn't george stephanopoulos one of the
people oh is it it's hoda and um
kathy lee oh yeah kathy lee well the guy
on there looks like george devanala sort
of
[ __ ] god they all look the same those
guys from experience
from your experience working with like i
guess
influencers or whatever right social
media has
given you more like what is it what is
it like fans
or you'll see more people cross over or
like
people will often say like i first found
you on jk
i first found you you or if i meet
somebody out in person
they'll say like all like i found you
from this so i will get way more
i found you from this and i would like
the steve harvey show or good morning
america
yeah but then that stuff probably gives
you some sort of like legitimacy
like in the public perception right like
they're like oh wow you're on a big show
i think not publicly i think it gives
you legitimacy like amongst the change
makers
but like my niece doesn't care you know
like what makes her
you guys made me really cool amongst
jared's brother his brothers
so like when i met jared's family i
don't remember how i name-dropped you
guys um i do it everywhere i go by the
way
but i said that he was like you know
three people from chicago's and then i
was like yeah
and then since then he started
pressuring jared to marry me so
he hooked me all alone
you got it good with the family because
you are a guest that's awesome
i think i made you make a video you met
him at the
baby shower he acted really cool though
because you're like
hey spark and he was like hey hey what's
up man
i watch your stuff okay cool what's the
better response
get on your knees and try to suck his
dick i don't know how old he was
that's what he likes that's what he
likes that's what bart likes yeah it's
his vibe
blow jobs from fans this is love
language right what
getting [ __ ] from fans no that's the
ultimate kiss
speaking of you you have a child and
you're a sexologist
when do you think it's cool to start
teaching a kid about sex
really good question right away right
really it's just contextual
i like that so as things come up like
yeah as it comes up
yeah and it comes up i think pretty soon
because
you've got some form of genitals so you
got to learn from that point on that's
true
and you start pointing at stuff on me
and you're like what's the point of that
oh
i'm explaining to you so i think if you
do it contextually
uh when i went to school for sexology we
had this year by year thing of like
what's normal at age three what's normal
at age four like and that's the thing is
like sexual behavior
starts in the in utero right and so it
continues in different phases and forms
so you have to keep
what's uterus like inside oh okay sexual
behavior what's something that it's like
you can see sometimes an ultrasound like
they might be
playing with themselves or touching no
they jack off since then jack
you've been checking off like a year
longer than you maybe a year longer
crazy that's crazy i jacked off before i
even could remember
amazing that's kinda cute
that's amazing do you guys um have you
if you've been masturbating for a long
time have you started to incorporate sex
toys in your
routine to make it more spicy uh i tried
a pocket [ __ ]
but then afterwards it was weird just at
one time
no i mean i got it and then the i i was
fine with it until
the girlfriend i was dating at the time
she was like oh what's this should i try
it
no she used it on me and then afterwards
i had to throw it away because i was
like i felt like i had a threesome with
another
sex toy like a sex doll we can't just
put that on the counter after and act
like nothing happens
put it back on the shelf it was like i
was
being disloyal to one to my pocket [ __ ]
with this girl and then she they met and
then we had a threesome and i was like
but this is not right i gotta have my
heart for one
and i threw it away in the dumpster oh
wow i have a question for you
so uh i think you don't have any
questions about that no did you give him
he's the one that
that that encouraged me to buy it
because he said it's bomb so i was like
i'm gonna get one too
they sell it to you because he you sold
sex you should have gave it at that time
i was finished selling them we've
normalized it here
but but i have a i have a question for
you so i know a lot of chicks
they uh they don't like it when
their guys jack off or masturbate right
how do you feel about it and
for you when is it a problem in the
relationship
like is there like white girls don't
like it when their guys jack up some
girls will like it yeah
i've been with some freaks i've heard
that though yeah oh jack off in front of
you or jack off period
i like to see somebody masturbate in
front of me for sure i love
i think it's the hottest thing i don't
know why what about a dude that's like
does it independently has his own thing
yeah yeah is that okay with you
okay you know what i'm gonna be honest
though because when i was pregnant um
my husband was like not into pregnancy
sex and so a lot of the times and also
too because i understood like
biologically how it was healthy for me
so i wanted to do it especially like
week 37
because you could start to speed [ __ ] up
at that point so what does that mean
speech it up
yo you can get more more closer to your
due date yes exactly
wow yes you if you have sex while
pregnant
only after 37 weeks you might be
wondering
where i got these real cool glasses
well look no further because today's
video is brought to you by
warby parker aubry parker
is committed to providing exceptional
vision care online and in person and
they got
eyeglasses sunglasses contact lenses
eye exams and even if none of those you
don't need
they even have blue light blockers and i
know we all need that because we're all
on our phones and our computers on our
tvs
so warby parker can help provide you
vision care and on top of that right now
we have sunglasses but what's cool is
they have glasses so
these glasses start at get this 95
including prescription lenses and they
got sunglasses as you can see here
progressives and blue light lenses
are also available if you need those too
and i'm playing with these right now and
these are some high quality glasses
the lenses are scratch resistant and
it's a strong frame and the hinges
work good and trust me i know i look
sexy and i don't wear glasses but i
actually wore glass my whole life
starting in first
second grade so i know what i need out
of my glasses and these actually fit
really good you know what i like about
the try at home kit though what
so with the whole rona going on right
yeah i don't want to go to the store and
try on all these different glasses
because what if someone was like and
then they put it back on like that
i do see them go and then wipe it too
yeah i don't want to freaking touch
theirs but what happens here is you get
to take a quiz
of your likes these flags and you
basically get to choose
five different glasses and faux free
they deliver this box and inside there
are five wonderful pairs that you
picked and you can try out with you your
friends whoever you could be like hey
how do i look at these
oh i think you know what you should
probably try the other ones
oh these are even better oh no no no and
then grandma's like no honey i think you
should wear
these these are like the best unlike a
normal store where you put on glasses
you gotta make up your mind like 10 15
minutes
you got five days five glasses five days
to decide
for free if you go to warbyparker.com
off the record and they even
have a prepaid return package so it's
literally nothing out of your pocket
no obligation to buy warbyparker.com
off the record to try these really cool
glasses and you can get eyeglasses
sunglasses even contacts
blue light blockers everything for your
vision care go check them out
is that bruno mars no it's not no no
it's not brutal bars
so it's not gonna do anything before
that but at that point it can start to
like
because the process may have already
begun it can just nudge it along
i'm being really immature right now but
is it because it's like priming the hole
to open
up because of the big dick
he's got a baseball bat it touches the
floor
on a curb so he has a giant dick so what
were you saying
no it's not that it's a kitty getting
ready to open
your semen has something in it that
helps to like
loosen up the cervix not your semen the
what's the pre-comb no the entire
package semen is one of the specific
um sperm no i'm right i'm right there
is the load so yeah so the semen has
fluid from the prostate that helps like
loosen up the area
um and then also when you orgasm you
contract and that can release oxytocin
and
that releases more than the uterus can
contract so like hurry up baby get out
of here i'm trying to get more dick
yeah so i was anyhow i was trying to get
have sex a lot and then he was not
and then i found out he was masturbating
and i was hurt oh
cause you felt unattractive i did for
sure feel on attraction because i know
that um
i heard that a lot of guys be like oh i
just keep thinking about sticking my
dick in and it's hitting the baby in the
head and i can't
do it that's how i felt too right we did
have pregnancy sets
uh sex couple times and it does feel
kind of weird a couple times in 10
months
what do you mean that's a long ass you
had twice in 10 months you had a pretty
i don't know how many times maybe yeah i
don't know but it just feels it does
feel
like it does feel kind of weird
sometimes you know
and a lot of the conversations is it's
like oh i can't be in this position oh
this position yes so it's just this
is yes the the pregnancy outside of the
physical form it's just
that topic is very evident in the sexual
part of it you know i don't know you
should just suck it up sounds like you
can do it
that's the thing is jared got like
smoked online for saying that
people were just like how dare you men
are so selfish and he was like why can't
i have a preference like why can i you
know not say that i
didn't i did but i just didn't enjoy the
sex that we were having yeah and like
also like if you're with your partner
right and like let's say
you want to go like naughty or whatever
and like you're like you want to
um be more aggressive you have a
straight up like
mom in mom's form in front of you so
like let's say you're into choking or
slapping now it feels weird you're like
am i slapping a mom or like
hmm are you not allowed to do like
aggressive sex when with the pregnant
woman because like does that
you should affect the baby i don't know
well i think i think like if both people
are happy do whatever you want but then
i'm just saying like the
there's a lot more that happens
psychologically for the dude when
there's
a like a mom mom yeah it's very slow
i'll say that it's very different change
of pace like if you want to change
positions
and you need help sometimes take some
time yeah need someone to kind of like
or you gotta like momentum yourself into
it yeah rock into it got a watermelon
there huh
yeah sometimes you gotta like restart
everything hurts like your
your sciatic nerve is hurting no not for
him he's fine he's just got to wait you
know
be like yeah that's well
yeah yeah i mean real funny no we're not
real fun
we're not wired to want to mate with
some someone that's already got a baby
in there
like i think just i don't when i see a
pregnant woman i don't think
sex with her i think protector that's
what i mean like the protection mind
comes on
so your your [ __ ] mind is kind of
like pushed to the side a little bit
it's done
and you're constantly in this protective
mindset even when we're walking through
a casino i'm like
why the [ __ ] is there like second hand
smoke in the air like you're you're
you're you're [ __ ] your spidey senses
are at an all-time high
is that you waving away the smoke for
your kids yeah yeah yeah so even like
when you're having sex you're still you
still have that you know
so you're just like i need to oh are you
too hot are you just you're just more
nurturing than you are like
this sex god a friend of mine was
pregnant at the same time as me
and she's a porn star and so she kept
working
for a while and in the beginning she saw
a boost in her sales
wow because she had a subscription
service but then people as it got
on were like this is [ __ ] weird
yeah but i think she was still having
threesomes up until like
five six months oh so you can like see
it you can slap a pregnant lady around
relatively then
you yeah with the right person who knows
you know i mean
i wouldn't give that as the takeaway
i'll ask my doctor
[Laughter]
i've learned that from you thank you do
you think you'd be okay let's say let's
say i'm nikki okay
yeah say i'm like this i like this word
she's like mickey's like
i'm gonna do this i'm so [ __ ] horny
right now and after a second
oh i'ma [ __ ] suck your dick like you
know it's different than if she like
especially with your [ __ ] nose it's
different when she's like
wearing lingerie is she nosebleeding in
this scenario or no i
don't know but wait a second i say you
look more beautiful than i've ever seen
you my whole life nice
did you let it suck your dick no such a
dick is much different from
having to have sex no i haven't i have a
tummy though baby
looks so hot i have a [ __ ] little
tummy
but going back to the masturbation
question is there a um
what is it like do you think it's okay
to have to
jack off and like does it make you feel
uncomfortable or like
if there is a girl and guy that's having
like hey
i want to jack off and it makes my girl
feel uncomfortable like what do you what
kind of advice do you give to stuff like
that you should reposition it as like
self-care
self-care so it's not about like math
it's not about not getting enough it's
like doing something for your it's
separate
like this is like you know what if
someone self cares five times a day
every single day
but then the sex is like once a month
more than that is that too much
self-care
you could still i mean maybe time for
the day holy [ __ ]
it may be like look your self-care can't
interfere with
our time together but if our time
together is good then self-care all you
all you need to
five times a day says you don't have a
job you know what i mean that's what
that means that you just care about
yourself
some people really care about themselves
somebody who had a job and had a very
strict masturbation schedule they were a
ups
delivery person well if you regiment it
out you know i'm just saying on average
on the job five times they said they
masturbated
eight times a day wow was he a cocaine
user
well maybe he kind of come fast is he
doing the back of the ups drug i know
i didn't he said i mean i the i had a
session with this person
uh this is back when i did counseling
and their issue that they were having
was that they
wanted to try their own [ __ ] but they had
a really hard time
tasting it did it yes they could have
breakfast took a turn this look
definitely
when you want to taste it sure okay it's
making sure
i think so okay but it's a care package
is it wrong to suck your own dick
i think if you can you should i think i
try to tell everyone
if you could why not you know that's
what i'm saying
i don't know if there's ever a wrong or
right it's your body that's literally
your body that's true if you want to
suck your own dick and someone shames
you
[ __ ] that person well what if it's your
own what if it's your wife who shames
you about it
because you suck your own dick better
than she can and yeah you're trying to
show her but then she's shaming you and
you're like
you you can't win if you guys are trying
to workshop blow job stuff
listen you know just listen
women can finger themselves better than
we can
yeah so i mean can we suck ourselves
better than they can yes
i don't know and if you're willing to
collaborate i feel like you know
just watch me a couple of times and
understand how i
like it can i get everyone's best dick
sucking tips
yes okay oh you're going to give us tips
no i'd like to hear that she wants to
hear
what we like um i like that's a good
question
when they get on and they slurp like
this oh wait wait wait dude again
they're going to tough
oh yeah do you know what i'm saying i do
they make the bubbly noises i like it
but i also i also like rim jobs like
crazy too
what's a rim job get my ass licked oh
you knew that this guy
he's got ketchup we got a couple of rims
i don't know oh i had a couple of them
you got four ribs you got sick rims
they're fake boys
and i can consider that a part of the
blow job for me oh
very nice it has to go the whole thing
like front and back yep i like a
windshield wiper
i like it deep but that's that's always
you know not always fun for everybody
i don't like deep throats i like it i
like the swirly swirl of the tongue
around the head
that's why i thought you were that's the
rim i was talking about that's not a rim
the rim of the penis
[Music]
i want that person to enjoy you know if
they don't want to do it then
it's all right how do you like them to
emote i mean you're an actress figured
out i don't know
i think it's on the individual i think
they should
if they enjoy doing it then then it's
fine but if they don't enjoy giving blow
jobs i don't want to you know
you want the emoting to be done in body
movements and eye contact
um that's a good question i never
thought about it i like the emoji when
they
use nice make me feel like it's the
smallest dick they've ever seen yeah the
shame the shame is good
yes that's good [ __ ] sigh shaming is
very good there's a whole [ __ ]
industry of that dick shaming
this man i love that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's good that's
good what's yours oh [ __ ]
uh i like the tongue action and then uh
more focus on the underside of the of
the dick there's a lot of nerves there
i don't know bottom of the boat bottom
of the hole
bottom of the
man i'm learning so much are we in a
session right now with you no i'm
learning from you
this is the first time you get to speak
to a roof full of guys
no right idiots aren't we but we'll be
we'll be honest with you
not in my life but maybe in a while we
are dumb
oh no but because in this room you'll
get straight up answers
and a little bit of trolling but most of
it is real yeah but the
every time a rim job is that real oh i
love that every time
uh i didn't know that i liked it so much
until i was introduced to it in my late
20s
but since then i was injured i was asked
like when i was 19.
my girlfriend at the time was like 23
and she goes let me lick your ass and
i'm like oh no that's weird
and then i look back and i'm like why
was i such a [ __ ] that [ __ ] was nice
and then uh my girlfriend at the time
when i was like 24 25 just sprung it on
me
and i [ __ ] busted without even
getting a [ __ ] and i was like what
the [ __ ]
by itself yes it just [ __ ]
geysered out like the bellagio water
show
like [ __ ] yellowstone happened dude
i was like what the [ __ ] is this it had
music behind it like yeah
i feel like i'm there watching it in my
head i'm like did your knees buckle
dude i had a [ __ ] seizure i was like
what the hell is this
i mean because it's not normal ass play
is not normalized every everyone was
like that's gay whatever right
and then i was like why did i not know
about this next level [ __ ] it's so good
you were hard and then you busted yeah
it was crazy
i think it was the person's technique or
just like the surprise of it
surprise the technique but then like it
like with any everything
it the the sensitivity and the fix wear
off over time
like now i feel like uh [ __ ] are
cool but then like i much rather will
get my balls licked
it's different i like you know my balls
like too yeah over
over a [ __ ] i mean i like both but
then don't concur
but in the past it was [ __ ] first
because i was like that's the best
so it just keeps changing for me i don't
know why i think enthusiasm eye contact
and yeah just it's like like if they
like it then it's great
yeah okay i like my balls can you lick
[Laughter]
[Applause]
too
[Music]
foreign